el cielo se vistió de rojo lava cenizas
y gases tóxicos pero sobre todo pánico
en la población en el territorio en irak
jamás nos preguntamos qué era pero ahora
sabemos que es una erupción del volcán
mira gong o
ya estamos en un estado de psicosis
total todos tienen miedo la gente está
huyendo no saben qué hacer
el gobierno implementó un plan de
desalojo en la zona pero el anuncio fue
hecho varias horas después de la
erupción nosotros los vecinos de
imagenio y otras periferias
fuimos hacia la ciudad de goma buscando
un lugar para refugiar nos en la ciudad
y lo que está mal y cuenta ante el
incertidumbre y la tardía reacción por
parte del gobierno muchos habitantes ya
habían procedido a huir hacia ruanda y
la región de masisi recuerdo que vimos
las mismas señales en 2001 perdimos
mucho y mucha gente por eso no sabemos
qué hacer no tenemos itinerario no
sabemos ni cómo actuar no hay
información ni siquiera en el canal
nacional la gente está entrando en
pánico y no sabemos si debemos quedarnos
en la casa o huir en 2002 fue la última
vez que el volcán mira gongo y su
erupción dejó centenares de muertos y
cubrió de lava las pistas del aeropuerto
más de 100.000 personas perdieron sus
hogares lo que aumenta la preocupación
de los residentes de goma